- [Voiceover] What I have
here are three numbers
plotted on the number line.
We have the number a, the
number c, the number b.
And then we have three -- (laughs)
we have four inequalities, actually.
Four inequalities that
involve absolute value.
And what I want to do is figure out
which is these inequalities are true,
given where a, c and b
are on the number line.
And I encourage you to pause the video
and try to think through it on your own.
All right, let's look at this first one.
It says that, "a is less than b."
So if we look at a and we look at b,
a is clearly to the left
of b on the number line.
So we know that this is true.
Even more we know that a is negative,
it's to the left of zero,
while b is positive.
Which is, if one thing is negative and
the other thing is positive,
the negative thing is
definitely going to be
less than the positive thing.
But even easier than that,
a is to the left of b on the number line.
If you're to the left of
something else on the number line
you're less than that other thing.
Because the number line,
at least the way we've constructed it,
it increases from left to right.
All right, the next statement,
"The absolute value of a is
greater than the absolute value of b."
Well, let's just think about
where these are on the number line.
So we've already said
a is three hash marks
to the left of zero.
That is a.
So what is going to be
the absolute value of a?
Well, the absolute value of a is the
distance that a is from zero.
So the distance that a is from zero is
one, two, three hash marks.
So the absolute value
of a is just going to be
that same distance on the positive side.
So the point that we marked as c
is also the absolute value of a.
So that is also the absolute value of a.
The absolute value of a -- sorry,
a is three to the left of zero.
Absolute value of a is going
to be three to the right.
It's just a measure of, how
many hash marks is it from zero?
Well, it's three hash marks from zero
so we put it right over here.
So is the absolute value of a greater than
the absolute value of b?
Or what's the absolute value of b?
Well, b is one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight hash marks to the right of zero.
And so the absolute value of b
is going to be on the eighth hash mark.
Because it's eight hash
marks to the right.
So this is also the absolute value of b.
And this is consistent with
what we've learned about absolute value.
Absolute value of a positive number
is just going to be that number again.
Absolute value of a negative number
is going to be the
opposite of that number.
And absolute value of zero
is just going to be zero.
So is the absolute value of a
greater than the absolute value of b?
Well, no.
Absolute value of a is to the left
of the absolute value
of b on our number line.
It is less than the absolute value of b.
So this is not true.
All right, next statement.
"Absolute value of a is less
than the absolute value of c."
Well, we already know that
the absolute value of a
is the same value as c.
So what's the absolute value of c?
Well, the absolute value
of a positive number
is just going to be that number.
So this point right over here is also
the absolute value of c.
So we see that the absolute value of a
is equal to the absolute value of c.
It's not less than.
So we are going to mark that off.
We could have written,
"Absolute value of a
is equal to absolute value of c."
That would have been true.
All right, last one.
a is less than c.
Well, once again a is to the
left of c on the number line.
So that is true, because our
number line is increasing
as we go from left to right.
If one number is to the
left of another number,
it is less than the other number.
So a is indeed less than c.
And we are done.